HELLO EVERYBODY  My name is Markiplier (Hi markimoo)
And welcome back to Flix (flicks) and chill 2! (grrrrrrrreeaaatttt (；一_一))
Now we're going to see the adventure of Frank... (CrankTheFrank Frank?)
or possibly-oooohhh- the adventure of Rose is locked (my name is rose¯\(°_o)/¯  )
so we only have Frank to go (﴾͡๏̯͡๏﴿ O'RLY?)
but that's okay because I got a feeling that Frank and I (...)
are going to get along, oh so nicely (¯\_(ツ)_/¯  (づ￣ ³￣)づ)
Hi–wait, okay, ((>人<) sorry I sneezed while typing )
why you look like me? (It is you ≧☉_☉≦)
Why you look like me Frank? (FRANKIPLIER?!?! ლ(ಠ益ಠლ))
Frankiplier in head : You force many to think differently about you; (see what I did there (─‿‿─))
that, charge they heavily to your account
You came nigh to them
and yet went past:
for that they never for-
Markiplier: What are you talking about Frank?!
Frankiplier in head: You go beyond them
but the higher you rise the smaller does the eye of envy sees you
Most of all however is the flying one hatred
Frankiplier : Oh Nietzche
how your cryptic philosophy speaks to me so (╚(ಠ_ಠ)=┐ I'ma just dance)
Markiplier: alright (explaining time guys ┬─┬ノ( º _ ºノ))
Number one, I'm not such a nerd as thee (mmmmmmmmmmmhmmm >_>)
and also
Nietzche, really? ((ノಠ益ಠ)ノ彡┻━┻)
I always believed in the other guy (our lord and savior jacksepticeye?)
Oh hello how's it going? Tyler! It's Tyler! (AYYYYYYYYYYYYEEEEEEEEEEE TYLERRRR (☞ﾟ∀ﾟ)☞)
Hey Tyler!! ((づ｡◕‿‿◕｡)づ)
T: Hey Frank, reading on the job? (uh oh ⚆ _ ⚆)
F: Hey, Tyler. Yeah–YEA* just reading a few quotes to get me geared up for the next 10 hour stretch.(WHY DIDN'T YOU LIE FRANK!!!)
These quotes are the only thing that get me through these 12 hour work days.((>ლ))
T: Well, cut it out ! We don't have time for you taking "reading" breaks.(...asshole...)
M: Oh jeez, Tyler!
Ya asshole! (AYYEE MARK XD)
T: My dad didn't start this company so you can have a leisure time. (you don't deserve the name tyler -_-)
We're here to make a profit!
And if you're not going to contribute, then you're just dead weight.
M: Let's see– Get the fuck outta– Who do ya think you're talkin' to?
WHO FUCK DO YOU THINK YOU KNOW I AM?!
F: Yea uhm sor–
M: UH OH AH that's not what I said,
I said– I have a lot of anger to vent towards your face Tyler!
F: I'll stop reading.
T: You better. This code better be top notch by the end of the week. Or else...
M: fauuuck you
F: Alright, well better get to it. Another cup of coffee will gear me up and get me going.
M: Uh I don't think so. Another– Another fistfull of vengence. This game could take a turn if i just decide to–
to start murdering everybody. Alright whatever
Cup of coffee it is.😐
F: Oh crap, there's no coffee. How the hell am I going to get work done without any coffee?😥
T: Oh yea, we ran out a few hours ago. Why don't you go to the cafe down the road and buy us some?
Will give you a chance to take a break.😒
F: Oh uh, thanks Tyler... sure...😒😑
T: I'll take a Unicorn Frappalappuccino. And make it snappy.
F: Uh, yea, sure.
(very quite) Fuckin' asshole... ¬_¬
Alright well, I guess I better take everyone's orders.
M: Why do I gotta take everyone's orders??😠
Why do I gotta do that??
Why can't I just get myself and Tyler a cup of coffee because he asked me and I'm a nice guy, I'll get it for him but–
whatever, fine.😒
Hello
Who're you
What d'ya want for coffee
(mumbles) don't stare at the camera like that.
F: Hey Katie!
K: Oh, hey Frank. Tyler making you his coffee boy again?
F: Yea I guess so.
K: Man I don't know how he expects you to get this absurd amount of work done if you're running his errands all the time.
You gotta stick up for yourself, Frank. Don't let him push you around like that.
F: Yea, you're right.
M: (repeating in agreement) Yeah, you're right.
M: I don't care if I have to quit!
F: But I could go for some coffee and fresh air myself, to be honest. Get out of this sweatshop for a bit.
K: Well, I'll have a coffee then. Black like my soul...
F: You got it.
K: Hey, you should bring Christina.
F: Chr–Christina?😥
K: Yea, I think she could use a little of a breather too.
Tyler's been hitting on her all day long.
M: Ohh-boy😒
T: Reading? On the job? How Cute.
K: I swear Tyler hired you to harass in one way and her to harass in another.
K: Anyway, it's also a bookstore, and she likes books just as much as you.
Plus, it's pretty obvious you have a crush on her.
F: R–Really?
K: Yep. I swear it's a page out of Beauty and the Beast,
and he's like Gaston, and you're like a nerdy beast or something.
Anyways, just ask her if she wants to help with the coffee
I'm sure she'd love to come along.
Just... don't mention Nietzche. I'm pretty sure she just reads romance
books all day and that stuff is not for the faint of heart.
F: Noted.
M: Alright, thanks Katie. I'm gonna go pick up this girl only because Tyler
doesn't seem to... wou–would probably pissed off by it.
F: Hey, Ronnie!
R: Oh, Hey Frank! Man, great job on your section of the code.
You're killing it brother! (༼ つ ಥ_ಥ ༽つ)
F: Haha, thanks!
R: you goingto the coffee shop?
F: Yep, my latest critical task by our favorite Boss.
R: Well if it's on company dollars, I'll take a latte.
Thanks, man.
F: No problem.
M: Heeyy Christinaa
Is that why you're name was? Hey how's it going? Hey
How ya doin?
M: My name's Frank, you can call me Mark, though.
F: Hey Christina!
C: Oh hey Frank, what's up?
F: I'm getting coffee, would you like to come? Want to come?😉
C: Let's see- Umm, I'm kinda working at the moment, plus I don't drink
coffee but thanks for the offer
F:What are you reading? Which book are you reading
C: Oh this? Just a silly romance novel you know, girl stuff.
F: Romance...c–COOOL ♥‿♥
Cool! Cool... Cool!
F: Well, uh...hey I'm going to the cafe bookstore to get some coffee for the office. You can come with me and get some fresh air if you want.
C: You know what? Sure why the heck not?
I would love to pick up a new book too, if we have the time
F: uhh. yeah sure lets do it.😳
M: Lets play hookie
Lets...lets quit our jobs and go get married
(more inaudible, now aggressive mumbling) and have a child together.
Uhhh...ohhh...so.
F: How do you like working here?
C: It's alright you know it has its pros and cons
just like any job
M: Am I a pro?
Am I a pro baby?
M: No（╯°□°）╯︵( .o.) (pfft HA)
Uhhh I know exactly of which you're talking about
haha you talking about tyler
F: Yeah, I know what you mean
Its good to have money but sometimes I feel over worked
C: Overworked is an understatement
You seemed to be tasked with quite the load
M: Quite the load at the moment
C: You know when I got the job I thought the team would be bigger
I was pretty surprised when I found out it was just the three of you
F: What do you mean?
C: Well it's just the amount of projects that comes through our firm is huge
I thought it was like some big company or something
F: Hmm.. yea. No that's just me and the guys.
C: Pretty impressive!
F: Haha, wow, thank you
M: *mumbles* Pretty impressive in other way-ah, ok...
C: Beautiful day today, huh?
M: Not as- NOT AS BEAUTIFUL AS YOUUU!
M: NOT AS BEAUTIFUL-- Are we talking about the weather now?? uugh. No
F: Yea, it's really nice out! A good day for *Mark chuckles* a stroll.
F: Really looking forward to some coffee.
M: Anyway...
M: Let's see
M: 'So what did you do before this?'
F: So what did you do before this?
C: Believe it or not, but I was a librarian.
M: SMART AAAA- SMART AND SEXY. No, that's weird.
'And yet you like romance novels.'
*mumbles* 'Why aren't you there anymore...'
I didn't tell her...yeah, that would be a mistake because I didn't...she didn't tell me that–
'Why aren't you there anymore?'
C: Ah, I wasn't getting paid enough. It was really nice being around books though
C: I really miss it.
F: You should do what you love! If you love what you do the money will follow!
C: Speak for yourself!
F: Hey, I do love what I do. I think in code.
C: Haha yea, I'm sure you love being a coffee boy.
F: Hmm...yea. I guess you're right.
C: Hey, who am I to judge? I went from one sitting job to another.
Still just shuffling around papers.
M: Hm.
M: 'Ask her about her' – LET'S TALK ABOUT ME AND MY DREAMS AND MY THINGS THAT I LIKE.
What're your – what're your hobbies.
F: So what do you do when you're not shuffling around Tyler's papers?
C: Oh you know. Romance novels. Tending to my cats. Going to the park. Etcetera, etcetera...
F: Sounds fun! I love cats.
C: Haha yea. Everyone loves cats nowadays.
M: I'm more of a dog guy.
F: True. Very very true.
C: How much longer 'till we get there?
F: Not too far. Haven't you been there before? I thought you get Tyler's coffee?
C: I usually just grab Tyler's fancy frappalappucinnos in my car on the way to work.
F: Oh okay. Yea we're almost there.
You know those things are horrible for you.
C: I get sick just looking at them.
F: Haha same!
Pretty sure they're delicious though.
C: Oh, absolutely.
F: We're hypocrites, aren't we?
C: Who isn't, this day and age?
M: *chuckles* Oh, we have so much in common.
'Let's not get political.'
'No one.'
'Cats.' Cats are not hypocrites they do exactly what they say.
F: Cats, hence why the Internet loves them so much. They're the perfect antithesis of the modern adult.
Straightforward about their needs. Compact. Low maintenance...
C: Self-obssessed. Think that they're the centre of the universe and expect others to pick up their poo.
More like the perfect counterpart to millennials. Our mirror image, really.
M: HAHA YEAH. US MILLENNIALS.
Sure.
F: Never thought of it that way. Maybe you're right.
C: Trust me I live with one. I'm basically an authority on the subject.
F: Maybe you should write a book about it.
C: Haha New York Times Bestselling author, here I come!
F: Not sure how you'd make a romance novel out of that though. Haha.
C: Psh, it wouldn't be a romance novel. It would be a philosophy book.
"The Zen of Maintaining A Tiny Self-Obsessed Person".
M: Hey, I like philosophy apparently!
F: Wow, Sounds pretty deep. I like it.
Ah, here we are. Time to get Tyler's...Unicorn Frappalappacino.
C: Did you hear about how that was like a big deal?
F: No. Tyler doesn't let me read the news at work. He monitors my web browsing.
C: That's...unsettling.
M: YEAH a lot of things about this job is unsettling.
But hey, not you babeh.
F: Alright, now to get the coffee.
C: Go for it. I'm going to check out the books.
M: Alright.
See ya.
Who are you stranger?
How are you doing?
F: Hey there!
Hector: Oh, uh, hey.
F: What're you working on?
H: Oh, just making some flyers for an open mic I'm running in another cafe. Wanna come?
M: Sure!
F: Sounds awesome!
H: You want my phone number? Or...email address? I can send you the flyer once it's done.
M: Let's see.
'Sure!'
F: Why not?
H: Cool! It's *Mark chuckles* Hectendo_64@Wemail.
Dumb, I know. Email me and I'll send you the details.
M: Alright, sure.
Coolio.
Hey, you're that bartender lady!
Hey, how YOU doin'?
Can I be a model?
F: Hey there!
Theresa: Oh, hey! You're Frank right? I've seen you here before.
F: Yeah, I'm Frank. And you are?
T: Theresa, good to meet you, Frank.
Okay, weird question. But aren't you like a super awesome programmer or something?
M: Haha yeah that's me.
F: Yeah, I'm okay.
T: Oh, awesome. You're totally the guy I'm looking for to programme my blog.
F: Programming a blog? That's pretty easy work. Are you sure you need help?
T: We really do. We're clueless and definitely need someone professional on board.
Would you mind helping us?
M: And YET you were trying to hire models for it already I see *whispers* the holes in your story.
*squeaking* UHH, alright I'll play your game.
F: You know I've got a lot on my plate at the moment but I think I can make time for starting a blog.
T: Oh awesome man! Yea, thanks! It's gonna be a pretty cool one just you see!
We'll pay you of course. What's your email? I'll email you the details.
F: It's FTakahashi@gigspot.net.
T: Awesome! Sending you the email.
F: Alright, cool!
M: Alright.
So there's some kind of interweaving story here.
I'm about that tho, I'm about that.
Hey, how's it do.
How you do.
How you doin'.
F: Hi there.
Heather: Hi, Frank! Getting your boss's coffee again?
F: Yep. He wants to try the Unicorn one every one keeps talking about lately sorry.
H: Who does he think we are, Skubrats? We don't make those here. We're a local cafe. We sell coffee.
F: Okay, hm.
H: Any other idea what he'd like?
M: 'Mocha Frappalappaci'– IMMA GET HIM NOTHIN.
GET HIM NOTHIN. NOT A THING.
Not a God damn thing.
F: You know what? Just don't get him anything.
H: You sure, Frank? Won't he like, fire you or something?
F: Probably gonna get fired anyway. Seems I'm threatened with it everyday.
Might as well stop prolonging the inevitable.
M: There you go buddy!
H: Gee, Frank sorry to hear it.
F: Meh, it's life.
H: Well, what can I get for ya? Something sugary to cheer you up?
F: I'll just take a coffee with cream. Sugar makes me crash.
H: Classy guy, alright. Coffee with cream for you. Anything for that girl you walked in with?
M: *squeaking* Maybe a– she doesn't like coffee maybe a green tea would be good.
F: You know what? I think she may like a green tea.
H: Alright. How about the rest of your crew?
F: Latte for Ronnie, black coffee for Katie.
H: Nice, I'll have those all ready in a bit. You can check out the books or something while you wait
F: Sounds good, thanks!
M: Alright, see ya 'round, see ya– see ya 'round. Who are you.
Hello.
How's it goin'.
F: Hey there!
Bookstore Owner: Sorry I'm really busy at the moment, But Heather can help you if you need something.
F: Oh, okay! Tha...
M: *breath intake* She busy wipin off somethin behind the counter. *grumble*
Okay, let's see what's going on over here.
Ooo.
Labyrinthian back here in this bookstore it is – oh.
Cushie down on this – ahh.
That's a nice *giggle* that's nice.
I'll get u– I'll get up now.
Okay getting' up. Nope. Didn't wanna do that! Nope, wanted to get up!
Wa- wa - I wanna get up.
Thank you.
Heeeey, how's it goin'?
How YOU doin'?
F: Hey, find a good book yet?
C: Nah, still lookin'.
M: Let's see– WELL HURRY UP!
'Need some help?'
F: Need some help?
C: Hmm...I don't know just kinda browsing.
F: (Unfortunately we don't have a ton of time. I'm gonna help her pick something.)
M: Okay, I will help you.
*singing* I am going to help I'm helping look at me I'm helping helping.
Apparently I'm not helping over there. *quietly* How do I help?
*more aggressively* How do I help? How can I help you?
How can I help?
Shall I get on this ladder and help?
Shall I get on this steppy stool?
Alright how 'bout this.
F: Haha wow this brings back memories.
C: What's that?
F: Larry Blotter and the Wizard's Revenge.
C: I've never read that.
*reads text*
M: 'You didn't miss much.' 'Well you should get it!'
This would be an insult.
*aggressively* Everybody loves these books you should get it.
*reads text*
'No, it'd still be good!'
Maybeh. Just because all I'd need is the scar on my forehead.
*reads text*
'Talk about childhood regrets.'
Ehhh. Why not.
*reads text*
Uh. I WENT OUTSIDE AND PLAYED TONS.
YOU HAD THE OPTION YOU JUST DIDN'T DO IT.
You got DISTRACTED.
*reads text*
Aww there we go that's pleasantries.
Alright you ready to GO yet. Alright fine then.
You fiddle around b – with whatever books you're diddling with.
I'll go over here and actually...make something of my life.
Alright who do we got. Who do we got goin' on here?
Who do we got. Hello.
Can I just get my God damn coffee yet?!
You got my God damn coffee.
Where's my God damn coffee.
Okay never mind. I'm just gonna hip thrust.
What do I do. Oh, am I STILL supposed to be looking for books?
*mumbles* Well, that's my bad.
*reads text*
I - Why would I lie? Nah.
'Absolutely!'
*reads text*
Let's see - 'I'd settle for the typical 8 hours.'
WELL THAT'S BULLSHIT I QUIT.
*reads text*
Not really.
Yeeeeaah.
'They can wait.'
Mmm. I don't know which one would be better. 'They can wait.'
*reads text*
Yeah, let's do that. That's nice.
Now that I've learnt the horrible secret.
That's keeping us all contained in this horrible prison we call WORK.
Slave our best years of our life away trying to do someone else's JOB.
'Ello. (x4) How's it goin'.
How you doin'.
*reads text*
Oh, thaanks I think so too.
MAYBE? Maybe.
*reads text*
Alright, okay.
Alright. Anybody else need a word of advice over here?
Hey you wanna give me some advice. Yeaah you know you do.
*reads text*
OH LET'S GO BE ADORABLE OVER THERE. *random noises*
*more random noises*
*quieter random noises*
Oh alright I can't walk here. Walk for me.
Scoosh.
*reads text*
'That's a good idea!'
'I'll think about it.'
*reads text*
Business. BuSIness. Business.
Let's see.
'You'd be hired in a heartbeat.' But kinda hard to date my secretary.
*reads text*
'Then we should start a business together!'
Ohh, things are going SWIMMINGLY here.
Oh things are going SWUMMINGLY. I think she likes me guys. Oo.
One last test, one last book to find. Let's see what's going on here.
*reads text*
No! Don't see my SHAME!
Oh. 'My favourite author.'
You know what, I'm gonna admit it. If it's my favourite author then I'm just gonna say.
*reads text*
I AM FREIDRICH NIETZSCHE
Oh ma gahd.
'Are you messing with me?' 'You can not serious right now.' I'd say this.
*reads text pompously*
Oh God. This is so sappy.
We're quoting a book together.
NUUUURHAHUUR.
*reads text*
'I think I' – LOVE YOU I LOVE YOU.
'Something I aspire to recognise.'
*reads text*
*kisses and whispers* Kiss her.
*laughs* I knew that was gonna be bad.
*reads text*
WOW I FUCKED THAT UP.
WELP I FUCKED THAT RIGHT UP
Oopsie poopsie. Ahh shit, there's no save.
GOD DAMN IT why'd I – I knew that was gonna be a goof joke!
Ahh if I have to go back and do all this again. *screams and squeaks incoherently*
Oh don't forget the coffee.
OOPS. Oopsie poopsie. Forget that ever happened.
UGH GAHD. NIETZSCHE be damned.
Uggh frick.
*random noises*
Oooh everybody awkward out of this. Ohh it's gonna swing swong – hey oh.
*reads text*
'I needed a break.'
'You don't deserve her anyway.' 'THIS IS AN OUTRAGE!' Which one do I do.
*reads text*
Let's see. 'Don't talk to me that way.' Don't TALK to me that way.
NOOOO.
'No.'
*reads text*
Throw it in his FACE. Throw the coffee in his face.
Throw it.
Do it.
Scalding coffee in th - oh okay well that's an option too.
*reads text*
LET'S GO.
*mumbles* LET'S GET OUT OF HERE.
*kisses* SORRY, caught up in the moment.
Sorry.
*reads text*
Let's see.
OH WAIT, that's not what I wanted.
Fuck. I fucked this up.
*reads text*
Let's see. 'Imma start my own business."
Woah.
*reads text*
EH.
WOAH.
Is that actually gonna – HEY!
*reads text*
YEAH AWKWARDNESS BE DAMNED! WE MADE IT! OH YAY!
YEEA – oh alright.
Oh man, I stumbled through the *chuckle* I STUMBLED THROUGH THE END ZONE BUT I LANDED.
AND IT WAS GOOD.
F: Me too, Christina.
Yeah, oh yeah.
You force many to think differently about you; that, charge they heavily to your account. You came nigh to th–
OOOOOOOHOHOHOHOHOO
*breath intake* YEAH.
WORKIN' WITH YOUR GIRLFRIEND.
YEEAH.
OH HELL YEAH.
Go Frank Takahashi, go!
My guidance didn't get you very good but hey, it worked a little bit! Yeah!
So anyway that is Flix and Chill. There are more stories here I don't know exactly how many but it's charming.
And it's ALSO GOOD to know that I don't have to be 100% perfect to have it work out in the end.
So there's Rose.
There's Jose.
There's Joakim Karud.
There's – OH oh no wait that's...that's the credits.
OOH no no no.
There's only two more. So anyway if you guys want to see more of this game let me down in the comments below.
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always I'll see YOU in the next video. Buh bye!
*fun outro music*